what's the trickiest gambit
the stafford all right new game
oh if e4 maybe i'll play the stafford
again
yeah let's do it in a classical slow
game
been having a good good track record
it's not guaranteed though
oh d3
and d3
so with d3 yeah i mean objectively d3 is
kind of just a passive move
i'm going to play dubiously
and insist on on the fact i can take the
pawn
so it's similar to what i was just
showing that takes i'm still trying to
transpose into a stafford
and there is a trap actually here
there's a trap of knight c3 knight g4
works
actually we could transpose into a fried
liver
in that line oh white plays knight f3
yeah knight f3 is the best move
and unfortunately
how bad is this
this might actually be really bad for me
i'm just down upon white didn't take
here
so now we see kind of the consequences
of
playing a dubious like really dubious
gambit from the get-go
hey i'm cuban i play chess oh but the
is about players you admire oh i guess
two out of three ain't bad
yeah all the players i mentioned all
right so if you think i am trolling i
will sub
first here is the hack so oh
i have to focus because i'm already in
trouble
and i feel like most of this game is
going to just be
suffering from a worse position like i
want to play d5 but
doesn't seem to work
d5 just doesn't work
well maybe queen e7 to prepare d5
the problem with d5 is e5
like i want to play this move
so there's a few moves i want to play
this move doesn't work
because d4 and this move doesn't work
because e5
so i can try and prepare i can try and
prepare something
like queen here maybe this is the way to
go queen e7
so then d4 is just met with this i'm
preparing d5 as well because the pawn is
pinned
and he fives under control
okay so finney finney oh love hate chess
is cuban oh
okay g3 is a very welcome sign
i was more expecting bishop e2 so with
g3 i can play knight g4
yeah i think i think white's falling
victim
this is really nice because
how does white defend the f on there's
really only two
considerations because any other move i
just win and when f2 and then just
have a great position if d4 i can take
here
actually d4 i win both pawns because
taking on e4 attacks everything
and the bishop e3 i'll have a pleasant
choice of
of which piece to take with
okay so what is a hacksaw e4 e5 knight
f3 knight f6
d4 oh
oh so d4 that's like a main line d4 he
takes d4
bishop c4
[Music]
so it feels like a urasov
i'll have to look into that like i
actually don't know if i can
i can answer your question i don't even
know what the question was
um
but i've i don't think i've studied that
one specifically
okay so in general the best approach is
to
preserve this bishop so unless there's
some concrete reason why
knight takes is better like it does
attack the queen but then queen e2
would probably have to take here
oh so there is a line takes takes takes
queen moves somewhere
and then knight b4 but then knight a3 i
think defends everything
so i'm just going to take here with the
knight
keep the bishop win back the pawn
i'll have the bishop hair
oh it's mainline scotch gambit
but there's no knight on c6
oh unless you met knight c6 instead of
knight f6
in that case i can maybe address
afterwards
hey the real easy peasy becoming a
twitch baby
oh you need a t-shirt you need your
t-shirt
but what t-shirt
i still have to make a a merch
also this move this move would be a
triple fork
i have to be slightly careful here i'm
thinking queen c5
where the queen and bishop can start
coordinating
there's a line to calculate queen c5
knight d5
i would have bishop f2
the king moves somewhere
and probably knight
so knight before there's d4
i'm not sure what's going on in that
line
there's also this move
it feels weird but it actually kind of
makes a lot of sense
simple idea i just want to win a pawn
and pin the knight
i'm kind of torn though between this and
this
i guess it really just comes down to
concrete calculation
about time i got that wrote back hmm
but which rook oh thomas probably
plunder the rook at some point
but wants it back thanks for subbing
thomas
okay i'm gonna play queen b4 because i
don't see how the other line works
and this just just has more nagging
pressure
prevents flight from moving the night
it's hard to break the rook beam one
would is just a pure defensive move
and knight d4 might be coming knight d4
takes takes when i
apply even more pressure to the knights
also shout out to thomas thanks for
subbing again
i think we have the thomas command
yeah positions like this i think the the
main question is what does white want to
do
why he wants to remove the bishop
probably with this move
but then i have knight d4 and takes and
then knight c2
so i think i just want to develop like
d6 bishop here
it's really hard for white to like to
even castle because the bishop controls
g1
oh chad is so quiet yeah chat was so
loud earlier
chad exerted all their energy earlier
and now now it's nap time for chat
a3 is a fine move of this move
so there's a line before queen jake's a3
knight d5 attacking this and this
then thankfully i have my bishop b6
i guess the line keeps going rook a1
the queen is a little bit stuck our k1
queen b2 rook here
white's controlling all the squares on
the diagonal
okay white doesn't go for that that's
nice
okay so here it's actually a nice
tactical idea
first time seeing that how new is this
emote
you missed the previous stream
the previous stream
featured all the behind the scenes
this was yeah i made this a previous
stream
had to carefully design each letter
da also there is a huge debate whether
to make da
or gah
and how many h's to include
and whether or not to include like an
exclamation point
but that was uh the final design
oh down d down d d
maybe the ds stand for da thanks for
subbing for two months
yeah i feel like da is just a
a synonym for oh no
oh no the light's unpinned
this is maybe an actual threat
also queen c5
i just want to control the dark squares
what do i have
do i have any positive emotes i have
let's go
and i have the the fork knights
and the london emote oh opponent
ooh opponent's back opponent took a very
short break
skills undercover thanks for subbing oh
extending their sub
been seeing this more more often
recently
extending their sub through september is
this a new thing on twitch
because like before this month no one no
one would extend their subs
okay i don't i don't actually know what
white wants to do here
because why can't castle i'm not sure
what the bishop's doing
but i know what i want to do
just develop this bishop slowly but
surely
controlling all these squares
oh maybe you just control how many
months at a time
interesting or maybe they changed
they may have changed something i know
they're doing a promotion of like
i think it's some percent off
not sure though okay so when i played
this i actually had a clear threat
which white did not prevent
yeah the the white queen is trapped in
its own territory
bishops are so powerful
i'm just controlling all these squares
with the bishops
and white can't counter attack my queen
because i just take with check
that was nice so that was a really quick
wow so i was feeling really
uncomfortable out of the opening
because
white played i played the best move here
i mean takes
taking is also possible but i would have
looked forward to a staffer gambit
um
i don't think i've specifically analyzed
this position
if bishop e2 then i'm probably suffering
let's see how bad this is
but this is interesting so g3 it's uh i
i think it's just another way that white
kind of just stumbles into a trap
and black's already oh i had d5 here
like g4 also good as d5 is
uh i should be on my radar
oh i can play d5 here wait how does this
work
what what
okay this actually works we're
discovering new
new opening new dubious opening theory
so i rejected d5 because of this line
but apparently
black and sac at night and then black
can stack another
knight and it's if it's only plus one
then this is probably
probably something to look into wow
queen h4 g3 bishop takes d4
and now it's saying plus two
bishop e3 only move
i guess yeah the other moves run into
queen e4
oh that's funny so queen e4 here and
then bishop h3
oh i would probably play this against
like a a much lower rated player
so bishop e3 wait we can take in queen
e4 still
oh so white wins back the rook and the
kings
okay white's still surviving here why
not queen h1
oh queen h1 doesn't work because bishop
e5
check oh that's so sad
but black and castle what's the damage
so black's down the piece for a pawn but
this pawn's hanging f6 could come
the king's on f2 okay bishop g
has this ever been played so where's a
novelty
well one one sad person played king g2
bishop e3
oh and one side person took on each one
so castling this is a funny line
and this is pretty much like starting
with d5
what was d5 played
let's play on move five right so
starting with d5
it's very likely to reach
uh the position after move 13.
like it's just such a flowing line if
white deviates from this line it's just
bad for white
i think
bishop g2 let me just take
queen b4 is tricky
and probably takes
yeah objectively white's better but it's
not completely dead
so black's not winning like computer's
always giving white an edge
but it's imbalanced enough and
the fact that if you know this you can
blitz it out basically to this point
hey it's pam welcome back i was just
watching
your video on the london hmm
but which video was it
was it the almost 1 million view video
or maybe it was a different video
good to see you also long time no see
yeah here we we don't quite have a
london have a staffer gambit
at least so it's not too often that i
discover
something like this is still a pretty
interesting discovery
because i would not i would not have
found this
so it's hard to consider this like
double sacrifice
it's so easy to reject